and actually that's the next thing I
want to talk about not everybody is
pleased about the expansion that I've
proposed to you for the David Pakman
show last week I told you we've got a
goal right we were thinking about is
that is it time for the end are we
ending are we wrapping up the David
Pakman show the answer is no we're
expanding the David Pakman show and the
way we want to do it is by strengthening
our staffing adding an additional part
time producer position so that we will
be able to have rotating staff vacations
and continue doing new programming
during the breaks during the previous
vacation breaks rather than just running
repeats and in order to do that we're
targeting 500 new paid supporters to the
show the most common complaints about
the show are David I wish that the show
was longer and had fewer commercials and
I wish that there were more shows every
year that there weren't these breaks for
one or two weeks at a time when staff
goes on vacation and I understand that
and the best way to fix that is by
increasing our staffing so that we don't
have to simply go off the air during
breaks and that will also allow us to be
able to afford getting rid of some of
the advertisers and replacing that
advertising time in the our show with
content so there are three ways that we
are building this list of 500 new
supporters number one and we're totally
agnostic between these three different
methods number one is membership right
you go to david pakman.com slash
membership you sign up that counts as
one of 500 if you want a discount off of
membership we've got a coupon code which
is vote soon 18 and by all means feel
free to use it
method number two is patreon you can go
to patreon.com/scishow
become a patron this starts at just one
dollar a month that counts towards the
500 new financial supporters and lastly
this is a beta thing that's available
YouTube sponsorship if you go to our
YouTube channel you'll notice that both
on the home page and on the internal
video pages there is a blue sponsor
button that you can press and this is
something that not every channel has
been invited to participate in it is
$4.99 a month and it
also counts towards those 500 supporters
now the good news is that we're up to 64
we have already gained 64 supporters
across these three methods towards our
goal of 500 the sort of sad news is that
there are people getting in touch and
saying David I hope you don't get to the
500 I hope the show fails the phrase
circling the drain is a popular one with
some alt rightous that they like to
throw at me in terms of what they
believe to be the status of the show and
we've actually got a voicemail that sort
of relates to the desire for the demise
of the David Pakman show from some
people in our audience I am confident
that we're gonna hit the 500 and that
we're gonna make an additional hire and
that we're going to do additional shows
although it's important to be aware of
the fact that there are adversaries
there are haters and every single person
that says hey you know what I'm gonna
become a member or I'll throw in a
dollar a month on patreon or I will
become a youtube sponsor every single
one of those people is pushing back
against someone who would really like to
see the show disappear and go the way of
all those shows that no longer exist